[Music]
2020 was undoubtedly the year of the
special purpose acquisition company or
spax as we have come to know them
these bank check companies which raise
money on the stock market and then
search for private companies to take
public
have pulled in billions of dollars from
institutional and retail investors
but as sparks have proliferated they
have also attracted intense scrutiny
from regulators
some of the best-known companies to have
gone public through spax have faced
investigations from the securities and
exchange commission
among them are fantasy sports betting
platform draftkings one of the most
successful spark mergers to date
as well as popular electric vehicle
startups nikola and lordstown motors
at issue are some of the key features
that have made spax popular with early
stage companies looking to raise money
for growth
that includes the ability to show
optimistic revenue projections in
investor marketing presentations as well
as a fast-track route to public markets
enabled by spax which have raised
questions around due diligence
wall street veterans such as bill ackman
have had a hard time navigating a
tougher stance from the regulator
the billionaire was forced to scupper a
deal to acquire 10 stake in universal
music through his bag following
intervention from the scc
the first major sec case came in july
the regulator issued fines against
momentous a space transportation startup
and stable road acquisition the space it
had struck a deal with for misleading
investors
it marked the first crackdown of its
kind and sent a clear warning to spark
deal makers
so where does this leave the spac market
the immediate effect is a significant
slowdown in both fundraising and deal
making
the long-term impact could be that a
large majority of the hundreds of spacks
currently searching for companies will
be forced to go back to their
shareholders without a deal
you